just let you know that the flight time
is going to be roughly uh a minute and
20 seconds today
[Music]
this is Westray Island Airport and this
is Papa Westra Island Airport there are
only 1.7 miles away from each other and
are connected by the world's shortest
commercial flight
the average flying time is about 80
seconds these two islands are a part of
the Orkney Islands in northern Scotland
this archipelago is defined by jagged
coastlines and it's obvious lack of
trees there are 70 islands in total only
20 of them are inhabited on some islands
like Papua Westray the population is
less than 100 to get around up here
most people fly on this plane the
inter-island Logan air route
Collin here he's the head pilot :
McAllister I'm the senior pilot the
aircraft we fly in automated cabbies the
passengers and the highest that we'd
reach about 350 feet altitude so it's
quite long it flies around about 150
miles an hour and it has the
aerodynamics of a brick but it's super
for what we do in the islands so why
does this flight exist because there are
so few people in the Orkney Islands
building bridges doesn't make financial
sense they just wouldn't get enough use
so if you live up here there are only
two ways to get around one you can take
this ferry which is super super slow or
two you can fly
my name is Kate and I live on me
mainland but I fly out to several of the
islands teaching music on a weekly basis
once every three weeks and flying is
your display to get to work
the flight is used almost like a bus
service it acts like a bus route but
it's not it takes a team from the two
air traffic controllers okay that's too
clear to lend to the four firefighters
they all work together to help keep the
flight safe over the years I've flown
somewhere between four or five thousand
times between Westry and Paco Westry is
community spirit that drives the people
who work at the airfields the world's
shortest flight has been around for a
long time the here have been flying it
for 50 years in Orkney at this point
it's a well-oiled machine our only
complaint no drink service
you
[Music]